thanks to the pandemic and the rule
changes from the cares act
american employees are taking money out
of their retirement accounts
at a crazy rate this is a problem
employees all over the country have
already taken out more than 12
billion dollars out of their retirement
because the stupid butt government told
them they could
this is a bad idea stealing
their futures from themselves i did not
know that number
12 i didn't either so i'm over here
writing it down going are you
serious the the sheer amount of you and
i
predicted that when the cares actually
came out and i didn't i didn't predict
that number though not that number
i just thought it would be stupid on
parade and it apparently is stupid on
steroids
the number of years of going backwards
just suddenly just erased
because the government decided to have a
fantastic idea
on how to save people and now people are
going to be working longer and harder
if they don't get plugged into a plan
well who's going to pay for it when they
get to retirement they're broke
that's right it's going to fall to
family members government
yeah so here's the deal if you're out
there and
you are in hr or you work with a company
it's time for you to be a hero your p
your team members
have the desperation right now at the
highest level
they don't know where to turn and who's
going to be there to help them
you have an opportunity to step into
that gap smart dollar will be able to
guide them
dave is teaching rachel's teaching i'm
teaching we're walking them through it
and people need hope right now so don't
turn a blind eye to it anymore
no more go to smartdollar.com 12 billion
that's amazing that's astonishing
didn't even need it
i mean dave how what the number of years
wiped out on average i'm going to do
some math to find out i don't know how
many people did it
but i mean that 12 billion
it's amazing i i mean let me because
here's here's what you and i know here's
why i'm groaning
we know that that money was going to
turn
into a hundred billion that's right
for the private sector individual
not a company not a government agency
a private sector individual to retire on
and change their family tree it would
change
their lives change their estate and
instead we know where the money went
it was consumed yes yes so
now chevrolet has the money
ford motor company has the money it was
consumed
banana republic has the money amazon.com
has the money
it was consumed and so it's gone
yep consumed means gone
oh that's just just the economics of the
stupidity
of what congress did with the cares act
the cares act is 2 300 pages long they
didn't read it and they passed it which
they've done that before it was called
obamacare
and every time how come every time they
don't read it they could put care in the
name
because they want you to feel loved i
can't like i care i care and here's the
thing they removed the 10
penalty but guess what they didn't
remove the taxes the taxes you have to
pay in the next
income to the irs was increased by taxes
on 12
billion billion dollars that they would
not have gotten this year
while america is shut down
in many places still
and people don't have jobs but the irs's
income goes
up so we can have a two-year ripple from
this one decision oh i'll try a decade
okay it gives me a headache i need some
pepto
oh i don't feel good yeah
see when you move money from private
sector wealth to consumption
and the government these this who got it
all the government got a fourth of it in
taxes
sure did easily and so the we increased
the government's income by four billion
yeah and then we increased all these
companies incomes yeah
those people were starving to death they
were not starving to death
we're not starving to death they weren't
i mean let me tell you that
not to that not to that range not to
that point they just said oh ooh
ooh i can get my money without a penalty
and that will step one
and in congress congress is so smart
they're my new financial planner they
said take it out
no penalty ooh that's all it was
was the little four-year-old and when
you have a four-year-old who who that's
right before you lose your
butt you get to uh uh oh my god yeah
oh the implications of the stupidity of
policy
so here's a i mean art laffer talks
about this there's a really good thing
to do when you're in government and
they're really good at it but they don't
do it often enough
nothing that's what they should do
nothing
let this play out nothing the ppap
loans are an absolute unmitigated
disaster
total disaster they're turning into
loans
the extended unemployment
an unmitigated disaster you had entire
industries trying to reopen and the
workers wouldn't come back to work
because they can sit on their butts at
home and keep getting checked
and make more than what they made
working it's an unmitigated disaster
when your government governs
oh god they got one job dave and let's
keep us safe
and where they yeah they're good at that
yeah just one job
just do that love our military but oh my
god this is just
i mean the i could go on for about 45
minutes here and i've got about
three golly 12 billion dollars i did not
know that number for real
12 billion and it's one thing if the
government loses 12 billion dollars
because they they they drop a billion
here a billion oh yeah that's not a big
deal
but these are people these are people
just lost their money they pulled their
money out
and in 90 of cases i know they consumed
it
because i know what happens all the time
oh yeah they can't tell you what
what what what they could show for it a
year later where where'd that money go
that we cashed out i don't know we just
know penalty but we
have 25 taxes we have a penalty and if
have just had an emergency fund in place
again harping on youtube
harping on this to get that in place
just get on beans and rice and do the
four walls and work three jobs i mean
you don't you don't don't it's a trap
oh god you could undo 10 years of
working and depositing into your 401k
with this one cares form one stupid one
signature
just undid that 10 years of work for a
lot of people
and let's not pay off our student loans
because we're interest-free
let's stay in debt that's the other
thing he did free student loans
no student loan interest so let's just
stay in that stupid
that's stupid oh my god i think you
could go down the cares act and we ought
to just rewrite it and call it the
stupid act
and just break it down for everybody
because the ppp loans
the extended unemployment the
from the feds no less the
now 12 billion dollars worth of damage
to individual wealth
pockets just gone it's just evaporated
you know how hard it is to get you guys
to get 12 billion dollars in your 401
case
and then you piss it away because the
government comes along and says you
don't have a penalty
and you go buy crap with it it's gone
you just consumed it
it just evaporated into the dadgum
economy and you'll never
and then you're broke you're broke
well because the government cares they
name the act the cares act they must
care
stupid policy when you start monkeying
around with stuff that you don't know
what you're doing
and apparently no one in congress does
it's the island of misfit toys
and they pass this stuff it has 12
billion dollars i just want to cry
the implication the legacies the number
one thing we found in the study of
millionaires and how they became
millionaires was their 401k
how many millionaires did we just kill
just
how do you kill how do you kill 12
billion dollars worth of mainers
it's just because if i took out a
hundred thousand dollars
in five years it would have been oh god
yeah we've just grown
oh my god all right we gotta regroup all
right yeah i need some coffee yeah we
need to do something bad
i'm down i'm gonna quit reading
government stuff
i quit watching the news because of this
and now i now read the news 12
million dollars worth of stupid oh
i'm so sorry people don't oh this is the
dave ramsey show